good news for the patriots cam newton is
asymptomatic he could play on sunday
against the denver broncos he needs to
have two negative tests at least 24
hours apart
the patriots are optimistic they will
have him this weekend they could
probably handle the broncos without him
although i don't know who they would
play at quarterback brian hoyer jared
stidham after last night i'm surprised
brian hoyer is still on the team shireen
but
you know cam newton coming back
cam newton being asymptomatic that's all
good news and
and
that's one of the reasons why people out
there will look at the nfl's entire
protocol and procedures and say if these
guys are asymptomatic why is it a big
deal well they still have the virus they
still can infect others and unless you
want to
try to achieve hurt immunity and also be
incredibly irresponsible and just let
the virus wash through your facility
like it's the white house you've got to
keep these guys out
yeah no question and you go back to the
titans i mean vrabel said today that
more team personnel that included some
coaches when we talk about others who
have gotten coven now we know shane
bowen the defensive play caller was the
first one the first domino to fall he
missed that week three game he didn't
make the trip to minnesota but you know
they have now have more coaches and we
know that coaches or a lot of them are
in that high risk category a lot of them
are older all of those things so you
want to keep this thing from spreading
to everybody else on the team and you
know back to cam mike i i think we saw
last night how much a good quarterback
means to the patriots i mean bill
belichick had a great defensive game
plan but if you don't have the
quarterback it's hard to win even for
bill belichick and the funny thing to me
was remember how we kept hearing that
jarrett stenham's fine he's going to be
our quarterback that's before they sign
cam and we're good with jared stidham we
can win with jared stidham
i i think you saw last night that yeah
maybe they can win some games but
they're a much better team when cam news
is out there at quarterback for the
patriots
yeah they got a glimpse of what life
would have been like if they hadn't
signed cam newton and we went through
march april may and most of june
assuming it was going to be stidhum or
hoyer and presumably stidhum so it would
have been a very long season for the new
england patriots if it had been hoyer or
stidham but
it's still bill belichick he still finds
a way and last night he found a way to
keep it close but for brian hoyer doing
something incredibly stupid the chris
webber routine at the end of the first
half where he thought he had a timeout
which means and it's not just the moment
where he gets up and he does this
that means the decisions he made
with the ball
before he's doing time out we're
premised on the notion that he has a
timeout left maybe he throws the ball
away
if he realizes he doesn't have a timeout
maybe he finds a way to make something
happen because he knows there ain't no
stopping the clock so that was
inexcusable for a guy and we heard it
all day yesterday oh he's so smart he's
so respected he knows the playbook he
does this he does that and he's the guy
that blew the game for them if brian
hoyer doesn't play like he did last
night we may have been talking all day
about how the patriots went to kansas
city and kicked the chief's ass
yeah it was six to three when he made
that boneheaded move and then he made
the other one later it was still six to
three and they were driving to at
minimum tie the score again and he takes
the sack and fumbles held on the ball
for an eternity i mean you've got to
have a clock this is not a rookie and
those two plays look like rookie mistake
they were bone-headed plays not smart
plays and it showed really why brian
hoyer can't keep a job even as a backup
in the nfl there's a reason he has
played for seven teams and you see the
reason why because when he comes in it
does not go well for the for the offense
and it didn't go well for the patriots
yesterday and they had a great defensive
game plan against patrick mahomes and
now we're starting to hear rumblings as
patrick mahomes the same guy hey it's
bill belichick he had a great defensive
game plan my home still won the game
all's good in kansas city but the
patriots have to have a core a capable
quarterback
for bill belichick to be able to pull
this thing off
well you know something that sims and i
talked about this morning the idea that
if and when the chiefs and the patriots
cross paths again
in january
if they have cam newton there's going to
be a different vibe the patriots are
going to think they can pull this off
and the chiefs may be thinking we'd
rather be playing the ravens today thank
you then or anyone frankly than the new
england patriots you know last night the
patriots would have won that game if tom
brady was still on the team i think
that's a given
uh the question of who starts who
doesn't start that will be debated
throughout the course of the week
whether it's hoyer or stitum in the
event cam can't play we're all hoping
cam can play because we like to see
greatness on the field bill belichick
addressed the
the reality of life without tom brady
here he
if is cam newton isn't available this
week um this is the plan to stick with
brian at quarterback
yeah we'll see how it goes we'll make a
decision on that
if we get more information on there all
those guys
start with cam
this wasn't last night's
where he did the double mask thing after
the game the first time i've seen anyone
at a press conference going double mask
this was today
double mask and sharing i can't figure
out
whether or not this is bill belichick
having an epiphany about the virus and
deciding he is going to do everything he
can to protect himself because he's
getting closer and closer to 70 and the
virus is in the building and he doesn't
want to catch it or whether it's some
sort of passive aggressive middle finger
to the nfl which read the riot act to
all teams including coaches and gm's
yesterday about
the the lackadaisical compliance with
the covet 19 protocols or maybe it's
somewhere in between or maybe it's both
but it's jarring to see
belichick going double mass going any
mask after we've seen press conference
after press conference where guys
typically don't have masks on
and he's not going to get fined
this week mike that's one thing for sure
you're not going to see the nfl hand out
any any letters to bill belichick this
week he was double mask and double
master in the game and
you hope it's because cam tested
positive he certainly was around cam and
he's trying to stay safe and if if he
has it trying not to spread it if he's
asymptom whatever
you know i understand they've tested
every day and all that but you hope
that's why he's doing it and not giving
the the nfl the middle finger but with
bill belichick you never know he
definitely could be and it definitely
could be both as well
i i keep waiting for one of these
coaches
who have gotten in hot water with the
nfl
to show up wearing like an astronaut
bubble or a hazmat suit from breaking
bad or something like that to prove a
point i thought sean payton may do that
week three
the the sunday night game after he got
the hundred thousand dollar fine and one
quick note on that
we saw john gruden
who had traded in his loincloth for the
jowls catcher chin strap on
sunday with the mask pulled down most of
the game and we thought uh oh he's gonna
get it the league's made it clear we've
huffed and puffed we're gonna
potentially suspend people who don't
comply we're gonna potentially take away
draft picks we posted on pft early in
the morning that that it's coming
something is coming an admonition a
punishment something is coming for
gruden and several other teams the nfl
just hasn't gotten around to it because
they're still trying to make sure the
fire's out in tennessee
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports